we looked at fractions in which the
numerator is less than the denominator
now look at the fraction five by four
is this a proper fraction
no
this is an improper fraction
a fraction in which the numerator is
greater than the denominator is called
an improper fraction
it's easy to understand proper fractions
as we select a few parts out of many
parts
but what about improper fractions
five over four
how do we understand this
look at this plate
it has four equal sections in which we
can place just four equal pizza slices
like this
but what if we have a fifth pizza slice
which you want to place on the plate
how do you do it
well you don't have a choice do you
you just place it over the other slices
we placed five parts over four parts
what about the case when four out of
four parts were filled
the ratio would be four over four
and yes this two is an improper fraction
so fractions can be divided into two
types
ones in which the numerator is less than
the denominator
these are called the proper fractions
and the second type is the one in which
the numerator is greater than or equal
to the denominator
these types are called improper
fractions
there is another classification we need
to know about
look at the fractions 3 by 8 5 by 8
and 6 by 8.
what can you notice looking at these
fractions
yes they have the same denominator
these kinds of fractions are called like
fractions
like because they have the same
denominator
now look at fractions like four by nine
two by six
and seven by eight
none of them have the same denominator
these fractions which do not have the
same denominator are called
unlike fractions
you